[Music]
shattered dreams for the future due to
the economic crisis that followed hot on
the heels of the pandemic many people
lack job prospects
that can put a strain on mental health
in mexico an online platform offers free
counselling
in ghana one woman successfully led her
company through the hard times and
managed to save more than just her own
job
[Music]
also one new scientific study suggests
that covert 19 vaccines can affect
menstruation
should pregnant women still get the shot
but first to colombia where one young
college graduate can't find any work
and she's not the only one
[Music]
amanda libertad walks the streets of
bogota like she used to as a student
because she currently has little else to
do she's among the 30 percent of young
colombians who haven't been able to find
work since the pandemic amanda scans the
internet and social media looking for
job offers she's exhausted pretty much
every avenue
[Music]
it's hard because you go through the
application process and they don't tell
you why you didn't get the job
i'm even applying for jobs i'm not
qualified for because i don't know what
else to do
they always want two years experience
and i only have six months
colombia's economy is still reeling from
the pandemic unemployment is at 11.3
percent while 58 of those working only
have a short-term contract or casual
labor
experts say young people are the worst
affected
job seekers with no work experience it's
really tough
those who do have some experience
already have a network of colleagues
young people don't have that they're
just starting to develop contacts
so the situation is really hard for them
the crisis is also starting to take a
mental and emotional toll on colombia's
unemployed youth
i have constant insomnia now
not just a few bad nights
i go to bed at 10 but only sleep till 3
a.m
and i get up at 6.
when i go to bed i'm thinking what am i
going to do but what can i do i have no
money no job and all i can think is
what's in store for me
when am i going to start my career
how will i earn an income
experts are alarmed by growing levels of
insomnia and anxiety among young people
they say it's an emergency that requires
urgent action
a study conducted by the world health
organization and local psychologists
showed that 70 of young colombians now
have difficulty sleeping
young people feel desperate and deeply
insecure when they think about their
future
they have no way of knowing with any
reasonable amount of certainty what the
immediate future holds
and they feel they have no power to
change that
so they're extremely
most young colombians feel they're
facing bigger challenges than those
experienced by their parents generation
i think i'll look back on my youth with
great sadness
your twenties are supposed to be so
fantastic
but i think i'll just remember how sad i
was
i remember me crying and being anxious
i thought my 20s would be awesome
it's a very bad time so we've just
finished studying in colombia and have
no work experience
[Music]
things are especially tough for young
people who don't get any support from
their family the pandemic has presented
colombia with a whole new set of
challenges
[Music]
in mexico anxiety disorders and
depression became more widespread during
the pandemic sandra vargas wanted to
help and founded apoyo
the initiative provides mental health
care that everyone can access for free
online
[Music]
at the end of march 2020 prior to any
lockdown measures in mexico
sandra vargas already predicted the
emotional stress the pandemic would
bring in its weight
the psychoanalyst responded by creating
apoyocovid or covid support
an online platform providing free
therapy
just fill out a form and get a list of
professionals available 24 hours a day
the immediacy and anonymity of the
platform were key to people overcoming
inhibitions about seeking psychological
help
because it's embarrassing and scary
in mexico the number of people
experiencing mental health problems
tripled during the pandemic
anxiety disorders affected up to half of
the population and almost a quarter of
all mexicans developed signs of
depression
pablo
who is in the program is one such case
often it was the pandemic that triggered
or worsened existing mental health
issues
it manifested itself in the form of
anxiety i started eating more and i
gained more weight i suffer from chronic
depression and had a major breakdown i
didn't feel like doing anything not even
going to the supermarket
[Music]
apollo covid quickly gained momentum
marco garcia is among its 90 volunteers
he feels the project is a good
opportunity to overcome prevailing
taboos in mexico concerning mental
health
here it's deeply culturally ingrained
that if you ask for emotional support
you obviously can't take care of your
own problems
collective stigmatization stops us from
asking for help it seems a weakness
so far the project's webinars have
helped some two thousand people
they've given individual sessions to
more than six hundred patients from
across mexico and also from other
countries
most of them contacted apoyocobid during
a time of crisis like monica cervera did
when she called from the mexican state
of oaxaca
the pandemic triggered the separation
from her husband
i was in crisis that day
i couldn't stop crying and i locked
myself in my room
my children were in the living room
it helped me a lot at the time apollo
covid really saved me because i felt so
lost
despite the increasing demand in the
last decade the mexican government has
allocated only two percent of its total
health budget to the treatment of mental
health issues
and most of it goes into the maintenance
of psychiatric hospitals
we're barely managing to deal with
diarrhea and flu we still have a long
way to go with mental disorders they're
not priorities
right after her training at the mexican
psychoanalytic association
sandra vargas specialized in crisis
management
she offered psychological support to
those affected by the 2017 earthquake in
mexico city
life is finally returning to normal in
mexico and the apollo corbett platform
is receiving fewer requests
but it serves to strengthen the network
of therapists who are interested in
reaching out to a population in need
it's a commitment that has to come about
in a very organic way
referring people to us who need low-cost
mental health care attention
have helped to improve mental health in
mexico during the pandemic and will
continue their work going forward
and now to a question that concerns
roughly half of the world's adult
population
does the covid vaccination have an
effect on menstruation according to a
new study the answer is yes
dw reporter hangshuen lee talks to one
of the study's authors dr catherine lee
of washington university in saint louis
[Music]
hi dr lee so according to your study how
did covet vaccination affect people's
menstruation
what were the major findings our
study took place um
as an online survey
and what we found in our survey um which
i should point out is not representative
of the general population because people
could opt into our survey but what we
found was around 40
of people experienced a heavier period
after one or both
of their covet vaccines
around 40 percent um had no difference
in the heaviness of their bleeding
and
the remainder of people
were about the same or maybe slightly
lighter how about people who do not
usually menstruate for example
post-menopausal women or people on
gender affirming hormones
we also asked
people who normally wouldn't have a
period for any number of reasons
including long-acting
reversible contraceptives
like iuds that suppress bleeding and
people who are on gender affirming
hormones a lot of those folks
noticed that they had breakthrough
bleeding and the third group that we
really focus on in this paper is the
experiences of post-menopausal people so
people who are at least 12 months
past normally having a period who
noticed that they had breakthrough
bleeding after getting their covet
vaccine so what is the mechanism causing
these changes
of course we have our hypotheses and we
what we think is happening is that the
vaccine
is making this big immune response
that's why the vaccine is so incredibly
effective this is involving a lot of
inflammatory processes as well
and we know that the uterus is already
an important immune organ it uses these
inflammatory processes as part of the
signaling for
growing and shedding every month
and so it's not unreasonable to think
that an immune response that involves a
lot of inflammatory processes
might disturb in some people
these inflammatory processes for a you
know a couple of cycles after the
vaccine and what it changes temporary or
ongoing
so we
have just closed a follow-up survey that
actually asks about this um that asks
how many periods or for how many months
people noticed any changes
we have not started to analyze that data
yet
but anecdotally what we suspect is that
for most people it's just two or three
periods that they're noticing this
i would suggest if anyone is very
worried they're bleeding a lot or it's
going on for much longer that they see
their doctor
um because there's probably something
else going on that is not just this
inflammatory response that we think is
happening for some people with the
vaccine thanks a lot
what would you like to know about covid
our science correspondent derek williams
has the lowdown on the latest research
and analysis just write to covert
producer dw.com
this week we received a question from
maria abdullia robledo
are there any risks for pregnant women
who get vaccinated
it's really great for a change to talk
about something where experts are in
such broad agreement
to start with let's maybe approach this
question from the flip side instead of
asking
whether there are risks to being
vaccinated when you're pregnant
let's ask what the risks are if you
aren't vaccinated and there all the
evidence is really pretty unequivocal
many studies have shown that if they
catch covid19 while they're pregnant
unvaccinated women are a lot more likely
to have severe outcomes
than vaccinated women are at this point
almost everyone agrees that getting the
disease and having none of the immunity
provided by vaccines
that that can pose a major threat to to
both mother and fetus that's why when it
comes to covet 19 most health care
authorities now view pregnant women as a
vulnerable group but are there threats
lurking in the background adverse
effects that maybe occur more frequently
or dangers
that's proven trickier to quantify
because
pregnancy is an inherently
risky proposition
even before the advent of covet vaccines
miscarriages for example occurred about
10 to 20 percent of the time all on
their own and women who knew that they
were pregnant
but all the data that we have so far
involving pregnancy and vaccination and
it's a lot
doesn't show an increase in that metric
like everyone
pregnant women can and do experience
mostly minor side effects after
receiving vaccines but
according to the world health
organization
many pregnant women all over the world
have now been vaccinated against sars
kobe 2 and there have been no worrisome
signs that it has affected either their
health or that of their babies in fact
the opposite could actually be true
there are some studies indicating that
the antibodies that pregnant women
produce after vaccination
that they not only help protect the
fetus from infection with the
coronavirus during the pregnancy
but also after birth
a fairly small one cited on the cdc
website for instance it tracked levels
of antibodies and infants
six months after they were born and it
found
that the children of women who'd been
vaccinated against covet 19 during their
pregnancy
that they appeared to be even better
protected from the disease than the
children of women who were infected with
covet 19 during their pregnancy many
questions remain open of course but the
advice has has really evolved and it's
now pretty unanimous
among health care authorities
if a pregnant woman
hasn't been vaccinated yet they say
then she should definitely take the step
[Music]
a lack of prospects in their own country
is driving people around the world to
look for work elsewhere after some time
in chile a young mother from venezuela
has been stranded in a town in northern
spain but here too almost a third of the
population is threatened by poverty
[Music]
liska sandoval never thought she would
have to queue to meet her and her baby's
basic needs nevertheless covet 19 left
this venezuelan mother without a job in
chile and forced her to migrate to spain
now she's one of the beneficiaries of an
aid organization there
i never thought of asking for help of
any kind
if there had not been a pandemic i
wouldn't have had to come to the cochina
economica for help
the kothina economica located in
santander in northern spain is a
charitable organization that meets the
basic needs of society's most vulnerable
among their services such as social
dining or a hygiene facility they
provide food to more than one thousand
families monthly
because of the pandemic more people come
to the commissary and the canteen to
meet their basic needs some people have
survived until now thanks to their
savings we have people who had a stable
economic situation but because of the
pandemic and its consequences they're
now in situations of exclusion
more than one million people have fallen
into poverty in the mediterranean
country a recent human rights watch
report denounces the administration's
failure to protect the most vulnerable
people working hospitality industry
single parents older people on state
pensions
really suffered during the pandemic as a
result of the economic shock those
people found themselves in a situation
where they desperately needed
state assistance through the social
security system and that assistance was
very very slow in coming and was very
difficult to reach
at the start of the pandemic the spanish
government like other countries expanded
existing unemployment support programs
but the furlough support left out people
working in the informal economy and did
not adequately cover those working
seasonally or paid in part under the
table
another essential step was fast tracking
the introduction of the minimum vital
income a social assistance program
introduced in may 2020 but it's only
reached nine percent of the people
living at risk of poverty
it's a basic very very basic low-level
social assistance scheme for people who
haven't contributed to
social security systems and what it does
is it gives a very modest actually a
tiny amount of financial assistance to
people between 450 to 1000 euros a month
what people found as they tried to apply
for support through the system was a
series of difficulties first in trying
to apply
in trying to document their need
in the way the system calculated their
level of need
it was a good system
at some level but it really failed on a
number of bureaucratic levels and in
terms of its implementation
spain is a relative latecomer among
european countries in having a
nationwide social assistance program the
experts agree it's closely linked to the
increase of those who live at risk of
falling into poverty
koldo kasla director of the human rights
center clinic at the university of essex
affirms that poor social protection is
spain's achilles heel
association espanola cuarta economia de
la horizonte
19 not only brought consequences for
people's health and pressure on the
health systems but also an economic
storm that has wreaked havoc on the
lives of the most vulnerable
now bold government actions are needed
to ensure a better and fairer outcome
in the midst of the pandemic a woman in
ghana has set up a training program for
women living on the poverty line without
any government support as fashion
designers they now have the chance to
make their own money a real success
story
[Music]
bintu baka lives in shokor
a deprived community in ghana's capital
accra
she's a trained fashion designer and had
been able to earn a good income from the
profession
[Music]
but then the pandemic hit and her
livelihood came under threat
losing a secure source of income was
challenging she says
so during the lockdown being home not
getting any income sure whatever you
saved is what you have to use and after
you consume all what are you going to do
next it means that
you and your family won't get anything
to eat and
you have to either beg someone for
eating food to eat chocolates of your
house or whatever your health issues and
other things so
it was it was not that easy
barca and other workers were sent home
in the middle of the pandemic after
their employer an ngo run fashion
business suffered a sales lump and a
sudden dip in funding
patricia wilkins is the founder of that
ngo which is called basics international
and promotes children's and women's
welfare
she faced the task of keeping baka and
others in their jobs
and keeping her organization from
shutting down
kovit obviously hit everyone
by surprise by a storm
it's not something any of us had maybe
lived in a lifetime of we heard about
you know so many pandemics that was so
many years ago but for us
it was a shock so nobody knew
what to do governments also had to
rely on studies and react so for us
i think we went through a panic mode
like everyone and we shut down
despite the financial pressures and
great anxiety patricia wilkins was able
to reopen the ngo after only a short
closure
many women were dependent on her support
and urgently needed food and shelter
back at work baca and her colleagues
expanded their fashion portfolio and
began to make face masks
they then ventured into making items
like cloth bags and pillowcases cells
improved dramatically
today the business is able to sustain
itself and its employees
i'm feeling okay i feel excited for the
fact that i didn't lose my job and it's
still
going on because this is where for me i
get my money to take care of myself
to
pay my rent pay other things
buy myself clothes and whatever i need
so to take care of my health as well
in ghana the pandemic hit women
particularly hard
92 percent of women who have a job are
in informal work
when an economic crisis caused that
sector to collapse there was limited
government support to keep people afloat
the ngo action aid ghana recently
conducted research into the impact of
kovid on the livelihoods of ghanaian
women
its findings showed that they remain
vulnerable
nationally women fall within the
informal sector now this is a sector
that does not have job security this is
a sector where happenings within the
country can cause a closure uh to a
business and so if you have
a a higher percentage of your population
uh being in that sector in their women
it clearly shows that once a pandemic
struck
they would definitely be the ones to
bear the brunt of this pandemic
but patricia wilkins is not giving up
every day she works hard to keep her
organization up and running without any
government support
bintu bacca and the other women here can
breathe a sigh of relief knowing that
for now their income is secure
and that's it for this week
next week we'll take a closer look at
what side effects covid19 vaccines can
have and whether in some exceptional
cases they might last longer than
expected
there are now years of research and
analysis that can be drawn on
reporter stephanie tsobel spoke with
klaus kichutek head of the powell erlich
institute to find out more
we look forward to seeing you next time
stay healthy
[Music]